Ich gebe es ehrlich zu, das ist ein Thema, was mir Angst macht.
Wo ist ihr Zimmer?
Am Besten nehme ich jemanden mit, damit ich nicht verloren gehe.
Wir stellen uns Demenz schrecklich vor.
Aber wie es für die Betroffenen ist, weiss man einfach nicht.
Hier ist jeder in seiner eigenen Welt, und trotzdem ist man nicht alleine.
Machen Sie hier einen kleinen Mittagsschlaf?
Wenn das Hirn nicht mehr funktioniert, dann wird das Herz umso wichtiger.
Man kann nicht mehr miteinander sprechen, man muss spüren.
Ich bin drei Tage in der Sonnweid Wetzikon, unter lauter Menschen mit Demenz.
Das sind die Zimmer.
Zweierzimmer.
- Genau.
Eigentlich können alle Zimmer
als Zweierzimmer genutzt werden.
Momentan haben wir ein Zimmer,
das als Einzelzimmer genutzt wird.
Dazu hat es immer ein Badezimmer.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi.
Grüezi miteinander.
Haben Sie sie schon erkannt,
Frau Egloff?
Nein.
- Ich kenne Sie auch noch nicht.
Ah, doch, jetzt,
die Stimme kenne ich.
Grüezi, Frau Egloff.
Freut mich sehr.
Ich habe noch keine Ahnung,
wer hier lebt und wer zu Besuch ist.
Sie sind hier zu Besuch?
- Nein, ich wohne hier.
Ich bin ... Wie sagt man?
- Eine Bewohnerin.
Ah, Sie haben hier ein Zimmer.
Wo ist Ihr Zimmer?
Am besten begleitet mich jemand,
damit ich mich nicht verirre.
Es ist hier vorne.
Woran merken Sie, dass es
Ihr Zimmer ... - Frau Egloff?
Ah, hier ist es.
Schon gut.
Das ist ein WC. Aber hier ist es.
- Jawohl.
Das ist es.
Das ist Ihr Zimmer?
- Ja.
Ich war vorhin erstaunt,
dass Sie eine Begleitung brauchten,
um Ihr Zimmer zu finden.
Ich kann mich schlecht orientieren,
finde nicht den richtigen Weg.
Manchmal habe ich Glück und erwische
auf Anhieb die richtige Tür.
Und manchmal
nehme ich lieber jemanden mit,
damit ich nicht suchen muss.
Das ist schon lange meine Schwäche,
und es wird nicht besser.
Es ist für mich schwierig,
mir das vorzustellen.
Wenn ich einen Weg ein- oder
zweimal gelaufen bin, kenne ich ihn.
Schön wär's.
Das geht bei mir gar nicht.
Und ich habe auch
keinen Zeitbegriff.
Ich weiss von der ganzen Geschichte
gar nichts.
Ich habe sie auch
ein wenig überfallen.
Wir sind uns begegnet
und jetzt sind wir schon ...
Pflups.
- ... mittendrin.
Genau.
Wenn Sie sagen,
Sie haben keinen Zeitbegriff,
dann sind Sie eigentlich
immer plötzlich mittendrin?
Ja, das hat was. Das stimmt.
Sollen wir Frau Vetsch
das Wohnzimmer zeigen? - Ja.
Also, kommen Sie.
Vielleicht gibt es was zum Rüsten.
Ich habe heute gefragt,
ob ich Bohnen rüsten kann.
Doch die Bohnen waren noch nicht da.
Ah ja.
Inzwischen sind sie sicher da.
Wir schauen gleich mal.
So, grüezi miteinander.
Grüezi wohl.
- Grüezi miteinander.
Frau Bosshard,
wollen Sie sich hier setzen?
(Als Erstes
lerne ich die Abteilung kennen,
wohin viele zu Beginn kommen:
die WG.)
(Zwölf Personen leben hier zusammen
und teilen den Alltag -
so gut es noch geht.)
Ich habe momentan selber
auch viele Bohnen im Garten.
Ich bin es mir gerade gewohnt,
Bohnen zu rüsten.
Sie sind viel schneller als ich,
Frau Schüpbach.
Ja, ist so.
Sie rüsten wohl nicht zum ersten Mal
Bohnen in Ihrem Leben.
Wie geht es Ihrem Daumen?
(Vis-a-vis von mir
sitzt Radojka Schüpbach.)
(Sie hat zwei erwachsene Kinder,
Wurzeln in Bosnien
und einen Daumen, der schmerzt.)
(Aber auch mit anderen Bewohnern
komme ich schnell ins Gespräch.)
(Mann) Vetsch ist
ein Rheintaler Geschlecht, nicht?
Genau, das stimmt.
Woher wissen Sie das?
Ich komme aus dem Oberland.
- Aha, ja, ja.
Aus der Nähe von Sargans.
Vetsch, Eggenberger und Lippuner.
- Jawohl.
Die hatten wir in der Sihlpost.
Dort oben heissen alle ...
Ja, dann kommen Sie auch ...
Das sind Grabser.
Ja, ja.
- Genau.
(Dass vieles von früher
noch präsent ist,
habe ich erwartet.)
(Mich überrascht aber,
wie unterschiedlich sich Demenz
bei jedem Einzelnen zeigt.)
Es ist für mich spannend,
denn man sagte mir,
ich treffe hier Menschen,
die eine Demenz haben.
Aber was hei...
- Ich habe auch eine Demenz.
Ja, Sie haben auch eine Demenz.
Aber was heisst das für Sie?
Ich bin wie kleines Kind -
ich verstehe gar nichts.
Das ist eine schwierige Frage.
Es ist sehr schwierig,
das noch auszudrücken.
Ich habe erlebt, dass die Menschen
manchmal kommen und sagen:
"Du siehst gar nicht so aus."
"Wo ist denn das Problem?"
Ich musste manchmal fast mit
dem Hammer auf den Tisch schlagen
und sagen: "Das ist mein ..."
"... mein Teil,
der nicht funktioniert."
Man glaubt es Ihnen nicht.
"Du siehst immer gut,
gesund und zufrieden aus."
Wenn man mit Ihnen spricht,
merkt man es nicht.
Am Telefon merkt es niemand.
Merkt man selber,
dass man irgendwie anders ...
Gerade am Anfang ...
... habe ich oft geweint
und mich versteckt.
Was haben Sie gemerkt?
Oder wie haben Sie es gemerkt?
Dass es ... Wie gesagt ...
(Natalie Suwald) Die Veränderung.
Und die Traurigkeit.
Langsam sprechen und ...
Irgendwie war alles durcheinander -
auf Deutsch gesagt.
* Treibende Musik *
(Demenz ist viel mehr
als ein wenig Vergesslichkeit.)
(Und wenn jemand im Moment
verwirrt ist, dann sowieso ich.)
... das Stationsbüro.
- Jawohl.
Mir stellten sich
schon einige Fragen.
Das glaube ich.
Es ist wahrscheinlich
schon vieles sehr ungewohnt.
Weisst du ...
Meine Hauptfrage ist tatsächlich:
Was für eine Demenz
sehe ich hier überhaupt?
Bei einigen wäre ich nie auf die
Idee gekommen, dass sie dement sind.
Wenn man einige draussen
auf der Strasse sehen würde,
würde man es nicht merken.
Es gibt aber Dinge,
die man vielleicht nicht
im ersten Moment wahrnimmt,
wie z.B. das Zimmer finden.
Oder bei Frau Egloff ist es z.B. so,
dass sie nicht alleine duschen kann.
Sie wäre damit komplett überfordert.
- Womit?
Z.B. damit,
den Wasserhahn richtig einzustellen,
also die Temperatur des Wassers
einzustellen.
Die richtigen Duschmittel
auszuwählen.
Das sind Dinge,
die für uns ganz simpel ...
Man kann sich gar nicht vorstellen,
was daran unverständlich sein kann.
Das sind Abläufe,
die für uns selbstverständlich sind.
Aber bei ihnen
funktionieren sie nicht mehr.
Aber ...
Ich war relativ forsch und fragte:
"Was bedeutet Demenz für Sie?"
Darf ich das überhaupt?
Zum Teil
sind solche Fragen sehr heikel.
Es gibt Personen bei uns, die
eine solche Frage sehr irritiert.
Sie sind auch überfordert
mit der Antwort.
Sie wissen vielleicht,
dass etwas nicht stimmt.
Aber sie haben vergessen,
wieso sie hier sind.
Und dann kann das
sehr verletzend ...
Verletzend ist vielleicht falsch,
aber es kann ein Schock sein.
Es ist bereits Mittagszeit.
- Oh ja.
Wir sind schon zu spät.
- Genau.
(Wissen-Sie-noch-Fragen
vermeide ich in Zukunft besser.)
(Die Menschen hier haben mehr davon,
wenn man teilt, was noch geht,
als über das zu reden,
was verloren gegangen ist.)
Hast du es gesehen im Wohnzimmer?
* Gemächliche,
leicht melancholische Musik *
Machen Sie ein Mittagsschläfchen?
Mhm.
Schon schön, wenn man sich
am Mittag einfach hinlegen
und etwas ausruhen kann, nicht?
Dann gehen wir weiter.
- Auf Wiedersehen.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi, Frau Schneider.
(Hier in der Sonnweid
treffe ich überall Bewohner an.)
(Alle Türen sind bewusst offen,
ausser jene beim Eingang.)
(Wir sind auf dem Weg
in die Abteilung,
wo Menschen
mit fortgeschrittener Demenz leben.)
Ich bin die Neue, Mona.
- Regula.
Dürfen wir uns duzen? Freut mich.
- Danke.
Natalie sagte, du bzw. ihr
seid meine nächste Abteilung.
Genau.
Wir sind die Pflege-Wohngruppe.
Und jetzt gerade Kaffeepause?
Ja,
wir beginnen mit der Kaffeepause.
Es sind 23 Bewohner,
die bei uns leben.
Die alle etwas mehr Pflege brauchen
als die Leute bei euch? - Genau.
Es sind alles Menschen,
die eine engere Pflege, Begleitung
und Tagesgestaltung brauchen
als die Menschen bei ihnen,
die noch vieles
selbst mitgestalten können.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
- Ja?
Ich bin jetzt
einfach etwas mit dir da.
Du hast Feierabend.
Wir sehen uns morgen wieder.
Danke vielmals.
- Ich danke dir vielmals.
Sie hatten alle schon ihr Dessert.
Bei Frau Schumacher
möchte ich nochmals schauen.
Sie hatte auch schon ihr Dessert.
Mal schauen,
ob wir sie etwas aufsetzen können.
(Auf der Pflegeabteilung
sind Menschen,
die den ganzen Tag
liegen bleiben würden.)
(Eine Tagesstruktur
ist darum umso wichtiger.)
Frau Schumacher spricht nicht mehr.
Aber jetzt ist sie
gerade etwas kritisch.
(Etwas hilflos stehe ich herum
und fühle mich etwas deplatziert.)
Sie ist jetzt ganz aufmerksam.
Wie kannst du jemandem seine
Persönlichkeit und Würde lassen,
ohne ihn zu etwas zu zwingen,
wenn du nicht weisst, was er will?
Ich kann nur für mich sprechen.
Ich bin seit 36 Jahren
in der Langzeitpflege.
Ich versuche,
mir immer zu überlegen,
wie ich das wollen würde ...
Wenn du hier wärst?
- ... wenn ich hier wäre.
Ich sage manchmal wirklich:
"Ich verstehe es wirklich,
es ist eine unmögliche Situation,
aber wir müssen jetzt
miteinander da durch."
"Ich brauche Ihre Hilfe."
Und manchmal funktioniert es.
Dass du das Gefühl hast ...
Ich bin immer wieder erstaunt,
wie diese Menschen
auf einer ganz anderen Ebene,
ich glaube über das Gefühl,
verstehen.
Mögen Sie aufsitzen?
So.
Du kannst zu ihr ans Bett sitzen.
So?
Frau Schumacher, versuchen Sie ...
Ja.
Hallo!
- Jetzt. Jetzt sind wir da.
Jetzt sind wir da, Frau Schumacher.
Hei, ei, ei, ei, ei, ei.
Das ist Mona Vetsch. Nebenan.
Ich bin ganz neu hier.
Sie kennen sich schon so gut aus,
und ich bin ganz neu.
Ja, genau. Nicht wahr?
(Die Sonnweid
gibt es schon über 30 Jahre.)
Sie gilt europaweit als Pionierin
in der Betreuung und Pflege
von Dementen.)
(Das Heim ist privat,
aber zugänglich.)
(Was wir filmen dürfen und sollen,
überlegen wir uns gut.)
(Wir holen das Einverständnis
der Angehörigen ein.)
Gut.
Hatten Sie auch Zvieri,
Frau Flammer?
Schauen Sie mal die vielen Leute,
die hier sind!
Das ist übrigens Frau Flammer.
Das ist Frau Vetsch.
Ich bin Mona Vetsch, freut mich.
Wir vom Fernsehen drehen hier drei
Tage lang einen Film. - Ja, gut.
Sie filmen heute.
- Mona Vetsch. Freut mich.
Sie haben Besuch.
Frau Flammer freut sich
immer wahnsinnig auf ihren Mann.
Schauen Sie mal hier!
Hatte ich recht?
Schau mal her.
Grüezi, Herr Flammer.
- Hoi, Margrit.
Grüezi, Frau Stahel.
- Grüezi, Herr Flammer.
Gehen Sie spazieren?
Gehen wir? - Ja.
- Nach draussen gehen ist immer gut.
Und dann noch was trinken.
- Ja. - Machen wir, oder?
Grüezi, Herr Flammer. Mona Vetsch.
- Willy Flammer.
Freut mich sehr.
Wir kommen aus derselben Region.
- Ja, klingt so.
Ich habe auch
einen Mostapfeldialekt.
Gibt Schlimmeres.
Jetzt gehen Sie spazieren?
- Ja, ja.
Etwas nach draussen.
- Geniessen Sie es! Bis später.
(Der Ausdruck
"einander an der Hand nehmen"
bekommt hier für mich
eine ganz neue Bedeutung.)
Herr Schumacher,
das ist übrigens ...
Wir haben uns schon kurz gesehen.
- Ich kenne Sie vom Fernsehen.
Ich kenne Sie jetzt auch.
Freut mich sehr.
Ihre Frau lernte ich
heute Nachmittag kennen. - Ja?
Zuerst lag sie
und dann setzten wir uns hin.
Und als wir uns hinsetzten ...
- ... strahlte sie.
Sie war ganz wach und strahlte.
- Jawohl.
Dann setzten wir uns
zusammen an den Tisch
und sprachen miteinander -
so, wie man eben sprechen kann.
Man kann nicht mehr sprechen,
man muss spüren. - Ja.
Es geht nur mit Gefühlen.
Sie spricht überhaupt nicht mehr.
Ja.
Aber Sie spüren, wie es ihr geht?
- Ja, ja.
Ja.
Guten Appetit.
- Danke.
Danke, ja.
Und ... mit Blumen.
Sonnenblumen.
Ich habe sehr viele Sonnenblumen.
Probieren wir mal davon?
Das ist ...
Sie müssen probieren, was das ist.
* Sie spricht unverständlich. *
Sie müssen probieren.
Ich weiss nicht, was es ist.
Probieren Sie mal, ob es lecker ist.
(Rund zwei Drittel
der dementen Menschen
leben nicht im Heim,
sondern zu Hause.)
(Bis es für die Angehörigen
irgendwann nicht mehr geht.)
Wann war der Moment,
als Sie entscheiden mussten,
dass Ihre Frau in ein Heim kommt
und nicht mehr zu Hause wohnen kann?
Ja, das ist ...
Es hat sich langsam entwickelt.
Vor einem Jahr hatte ich das Gefühl,
es gehe nicht mehr lang.
Und dann habe ich im ...
- Sie haben sie so lange daheim ...
Ich habe sie gepflegt,
alleine gepflegt, solange es ging.
Das ist eigentlich normal ...
Wir sind 52 Jahre verheiratet,
da ist es normal,
dass man zueinander schaut.
Vor ca. einem Jahr, im letzten Jahr,
konnte sie nicht mal mehr
die Tasse abtrocknen,
keine Karotten mehr schneiden,
nichts mehr.
Essen konnte sie nur noch von Hand.
Die Pflege war nicht so schlimm.
Aber sie verweigerte
manchmal meine Hilfe.
Und als sie zudem nicht mehr
essen wollte, wurde es schwieriger.
Denken Sie manchmal an den Moment,
wenn Ihre Frau
Sie auch nicht mehr kennt?
Das wird irgendwann kommen,
das weiss ich.
Man weiss ungefähr, wie es abläuft.
Nur der Zeitrahmen ist ungewiss.
Es kann fünf Jahre dauern
oder zwei, ich weiss es nicht.
(Bei Demenz ist eine Person krank,
aber eine ganze Familie betroffen.)
(Das ist auch bei Schüpbachs so.)
(Mutter Radojka bekommt
gerade Besuch von Tochter Barbara.)
Schau. Wer ist das?
Oh, die Brille. Hast du die Brille?
Ich weiss nicht.
Ich schaue mal,
ob sie hier drin ist.
Wer könnte das sein?
Ja, wer könnte das sein?
Vielleicht mit Brille ...
Trudi?
- Jawohl!
Das ist Trudeli.
- Grossmami.
Das war auf der Hochzeitsreise.
Als sie zusammen mit Papi ...
- Ja!
Ach ja. Und ich ...
- Wo waren sie? In Davos?
Ja, Davos. Ja, ja.
Und ich und Ursi
mussten mit den Kühen ...
Hinter uns Ochsen und Kühe
und alles.
Und wir rüber ... Wupp!
Mit der Brille siehst du hier ...
Schau!
Schau, Mami!
- Ja.
(Bevor mein erster Tag
in der Sonnweid zu Ende geht,
schaue ich noch
bei der Oase vorbei.)
(Hier leben Menschen
mit einer schweren Demenz.)
(Und das nicht etwa
in Einzelzimmern -
zu meiner Überraschung
liegen sie zusammen in einem Raum.)
* Ruhige, bedächtige Klaviermusik *
(Um 7 Uhr
treffen wir uns zum Morgenrapport.)
(Es war offenbar
einiges los in der Nacht.)
Herr Wettler
ist um 3.30 Uhr aufgestanden.
Er hatte seine Hosen
schon angezogen.
Ich sagte ihm,
er könne noch etwas schlafen.
Dann ging er nochmals ins Bett.
(Wer aufgestanden ist,
geht frühstücken.)
Wollen Sie Honig oder Konfitüre?
Leche fria.
- Jawohl.
Du bist Willi aus dem Pizol, nicht?
- Ja.
Wangs, Pizol.
- Ah, Wangs, ja.
Schlafen Sie jeweils gut?
Normalerweise
wäre ich schon lange wach.
Sind Sie eine Frühaufsteherin?
- Danke.
(Flüsternd)
Darum: Entschuldigung.
Aber Schlafen ist gesund,
das weiss ich.
Und wir haben ja nichts abgemacht.
Nein, wir haben nichts abgemacht.
Mir sagten sie, jeder
könne aufstehen, wann er wolle.
Es gibt keine bestimme Zeit.
Wie gesagt: Das ist selten.
- Immer bei den Frühsten dabei?
(Die Menschen in der WG
sind noch relativ selbstständig.)
(Jene in der Oase
überhaupt nicht mehr.)
(Das Bild dieser Menschen,
alle zusammen in einem grossen Raum,
ging mir nachts nicht aus dem Kopf.)
(Michael Schmieder
ist der Gründer der Sonnweid.)
Wenn man das erste Mal hier ist,
setzt es einem
im ersten Moment ziemlich zu,
wenn man sieht, dass so viele
Menschen in einem Raum liegen.
Wie hat das begonnen?
Was war die Intention?
Früher in unserem Altbau
hatten wir einen Pflegesaal.
Dort waren zwölf Plätze.
Als wir ihn renovierten,
haben wir das Personal gefragt:
"Was stellt ihr euch vor für eine
optimale Betreuung dieser Menschen?"
"Alles ist möglich,
nur keine Einerzimmer."
Obwohl man denken würde,
dass es genau das braucht.
Jeder für sich, Individualität.
Dann überlegten wir uns:
"Was erlebt
ein Mensch im hohen Alter
mit einer schweren,
sehr schweren Demenzerkrankung?"
Wir merkten, dass er eigentlich
nur noch die Gruppe erlebt.
Wenn wir ein paar
Hunderttausend Jahre zurückgehen -
der Mensch lebte immer
in einer Gemeinschaft.
Und seit 50, 60 Jahren
haben wir das Gefühl,
das Einerzimmer sei
die Errungenschaft der Menschheit.
Wenn der Mensch
das Ende seines Lebens erreicht,
ist er auf ein soziales Bezugsfeld
angewiesen.
Und das sind Menschen
auf diesem Weg.
Wir glauben, dass die Gemeinschaft
eine grosse Sicherheit gibt.
Was ist das Wichtigste,
was muss man lernen im Umgang
mit demenzkranken Menschen?
Das, was für uns möglich ist:
die Beziehung.
Die Beziehung und zu jemandem
Ja sagen - egal, wer er ist.
Auch wenn das Normverständnis
ein anderes ist.
Man leidet ja immer darunter,
dass Menschen mit Demenz
andere Normen haben.
Was heisst "andere Normen"?
Es kann z.B. sein,
dass jemand auf den Boden uriniert.
Jetzt stellt sich die Frage,
ob ich ein Drama daraus mache
oder die Situation so akzeptiere
und aufwische.
Es gibt auch
sehr kuriose Geschichten,
dass jemand einem
sofort einen Kuss gibt usw.
Dann hat das immer damit zu tun,
dass ich
ein Beziehungsangebot mache.
Der Bewohner hat damit auch eine
Möglichkeit, sich sicher zu fühlen.
Er fühlt sich nur noch sicher über
die Beziehung zu anderen Menschen.
Wenn man alles verliert,
das logische Denken und alles,
bleibt am Schluss
die Nähe zu Menschen?
Ja, und das Emotionale.
Und darauf baut ihr?
- Ja.
Danke vielmals
- Gern geschehen.
* Sanfte, gläserne Klänge *
(Heilbar ist Demenz nicht.
Der Tod hat hier seinen Platz.)
(Das sind Tonfiguren,
hergestellt von Bewohnern.)
(Jede erinnert an einen Menschen,
auch wenn dieser nicht mehr da ist.)
Hier habe ich zwei
schon ein wenig ausgerollt.
Da kann ich auch noch ...
- Uh, er klebt fast.
Ui, ui, ui, ui.
Schauen Sie mal, Frau Schüpbach,
wenn wir sie so aufrichten ...
Ist ja verrückt!
- ... ist es schon fast eine Figur.
Tipptopp.
Jetzt könnte man etwas ...
Wenn Sie wollen,
dürfen Sie einen Kopf formen.
Er kann auch ganz einfach sein.
Hier oben wäre also der Kopf?
- Ja.
Mich nimmt wunder, was das wird.
Aber es könnte etwas Gutes werden.
Man darf nicht
immer nur negativ denken.
Es wäre eben süss ...
Das könnte halten.
Das gleicht einer Nase.
Und das hier wären ...
... wären irgendwie Augen.
Die zwei da.
Betrachten wir sie doch mal.
Schauen Sie mal!
Sieht interessant aus.
Das ist irgendwie ...
- Etwas ganz Eigenes von Ihnen.
Mir gefällt die Stelle hier.
- Ja, genau.
Das hier. Und das hier.
Derjenige, der das gemacht hat  ...
* Gemächliche,
leicht melancholische Musik *
(Am Abend nach der Arbeit
besucht Barbara Schüpbach
wieder ihre Mutter.)
(Die Familie lebte früher
auf der ganzen Welt.)
Schau mal,
was ich gefunden habe, Mami.
Deine rote Lesebrille.
Ah.
Weisst du noch,
woher gewisse Souvenirs sind?
Natürlich weiss ich,
woher sie stammen.
Pakistan, nicht?
- Ja, da bin ich mir sicher.
Und der kleine Teppich auch, nicht?
Den habe ich dir auch mitgebracht.
Der kleine Teppich.
Und sie hier
ist aus Indonesien, nicht?
Ja.
- Sehr international.
Schauen wir mal, ob die neuen Hosen
schon wieder zurück sind.
Sie mussten sie noch anschreiben.
Hier oben sind sie.
- Ja, ist schon gut.
Ist gut?
- Ja, ich bin gerne unterwegs.
* Sanfte, gläserne Klänge *
Wie war es, als du und dein Bruder
für eure Mutter entscheiden musstet,
dass sie hierherkommt?
Von sich aus wäre sie wohl nicht
gegangen. - Von sich aus, nein.
Ich wusste,
dass ich im Mai in die Ferien gehe.
Ich sah die Möglichkeit,
dass sie,
während ich in den Ferien weile,
ihre Ferien
zur Probe hier verbringt.
Genau eine Woche,
bevor ich in die Ferien ging,
gab es bei ihr zu Hause
eine Situation,
da bekam sie eine solche Angst
in der Wohnung, dass sie weglief.
Die Nachbarn
haben sie dann im Zentrum gefunden.
Sie weinte.
Sie haben mich angerufen und gesagt,
dass meine Mutter wirr sei, weine
und sage,
sie könne nicht mehr nach Hause.
Im ersten Moment
wusste ich nicht, wie weiter.
Ich habe dann den Arzt
im Unispital angerufen.
Wir haben es mit ihm besprochen,
und er hat gesagt,
dass sie
notfallmässig eingewiesen werde.
Dann war sie eine Woche dort
und bekam auch etwas
gegen die Angstzustände,
die immer schlimmer wurden.
Danach haben wir
den Entscheid gefällt.
Wir hatten Glück,
dass ein Platz frei wurde -
das ist auch nicht
selbstverständlich.
Es war schwierig.
Als ich sie in Regensdorf abholte
und mit ihr ins Unispital fuhr,
sagte sie:
"Ich komme nicht mehr zurück."
Das war schon ...
Das hat sie gesagt,
das hat sie gewusst. - Ja.
Was hast du geantwortet?
Ich war dazu nicht in der Lage.
Ja.
Es wäre schöner gewesen, wenn sie
selber hätte entscheiden können.
Wie ist es für dich als Tochter,
wenn du merkst,
dass du deine eigene Mutter
Stück für Stück
immer ein wenig mehr verlierst?
Für mich und meinen Bruder
ist es schwierig, zu sehen,
dass sie Stück für Stück abbaut.
Momentan ist sie in einer Phase,
in der sie es mitbekommt.
Das stresst sie auch.
Wir können nichts machen,
verspüren eine Hilflosigkeit.
Das ist schon ...
Es ist nicht einfach,
damit umzugehen,
wenn man sieht,
dass man einen Menschen
mehr und mehr verliert.
Jemanden, den man lieb hat.
Den man lieb hat.
Und es ist ... Ja.
Was kannst du ihr geben?
Oder was willst du ihr noch geben?
Sie soll wissen,
dass wir für sie da sind.
Ich hoffe, dass wir ihr
mit unseren Entscheidungen
noch eine Lebensqualität
ermöglichen können.
Für mich und meinen Bruder
ist das am wichtigsten.
Denn es ist für mich
immer noch ein lebenswertes Leben.
Das ist es.
- Und das finde ich wichtig.
Ja. Ja.
* Sanfte, gläserne Klänge *
(Mein dritter Morgen
in der Sonnweid.)
(Ich würde mich auf der Pflege-
station gerne nützlich machen.)
Kann ich helfen?
Ich verschaffe mir
gerade einen Überblick.
Sie hier haben schon gefrühstückt.
- Ah, ja.
Ich muss rasch schauen.
Es sind wirklich noch alle im Bett.
Teilweise sind sie noch im Bett.
Wenn ich als Angehörige
hierherkommen würde und sehe,
dass mein Vater oder mein Mann
nur dasitzen
und eigentlich nichts machen würde:
Ist ihm dann langweilig,
lässt man ihn sitzen,
muss man ihn beschäftigen,
wie ist das?
Wir haben als Pflegepersonen
immer wieder das Bedürfnis,
die Menschen zu beschäftigen,
wobei wir das für uns tun.
Letzthin sagte mir jemand,
wenn sie neben Frau Flammer sitze,
sitze diese einfach da,
schaue sie an,
und sie habe das Gefühl,
sie könne nichts machen.
Ich muss doch ...
Was mache ich jetzt?
Dann biete ich ihr etwas an,
und sie will nicht.
Wenn ich aber gehe,
hält sie mich zurück.
Dann muss ich lernen, auszuhalten,
dass ich jetzt einfach hier bin.
Die vier Leute frühstücken,
sie sind bei sich.
Ich habe bei keinem das Gefühl,
ich müsse jetzt eingreifen
und ein Gespräch anzetteln.
Etwas machen,
eine Reaktion auslösen.
Man kann also auch mal
Fünfe gerade sein lassen
und einfach bei ihnen sitzen.
- Ja.
* Ruhige,
leicht melancholische Musik *
(Lernen zu akzeptieren,
dass eine Demenz einen Menschen
und seine Bedürfnisse verändert,
auch wenn das für uns Gesunde manch-
mal schwer nachvollziehbar ist.)
Guten Morgen, Herr Flammer.
- Guten Morgen.
(Einfach da sein.)
Wie geht's?
- Guten Morgen. Gut. - Hoi.
Hoi du.
- Schon wieder hier, nicht?
Darf ich mich setzen?
- Ja.
(Und miteinander
ganz im Moment leben.)
(Das nehme ich mit nach drei Tagen
im Heim für Menschen mit Demenz.)
(Auch wenn sich alles auflöst
und jemand
in seiner eigenen Welt versinkt -
das Bedürfnis nach Nähe
bleibt eine Leben lang.)